hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous êtes en boîte de nuit de
province vous avez raconté que vous vous
transformez en prédateur ouais je
deviens un blaireau quoi c'est vrai
pourquoi les que j'entends la musique
des mots comme vous voulez qu'on vous
l'a baptisé metella avait un premier
temps
fribourg
[Rires]
jusqu'au jour où pauline une journaliste
d'où ces séduisantes fait irruption dans
leur vie et ça et ça hein c'est
parfaitement ça va très bien merci
ça promet la mise en scène faire passer
avec ce très bas oui tout à l'heure
mauvais si gentiment watts
[Applaudissements]
vous prête à dire pour avoir une
relation justement avec jean michel
maire le brocoli sa masse totale
impeccable est content d'être avec nous
fait soifia pas d'eau non amer ce qui
vas tu sais qu'on passe à l'antenne
adacore merci merci ca va manger